100 years ago after the war
system they believed would create
lasting peace they divided society into
five factions the only way you can
survive is for each of you to claim your
rightful place
everyone is tested to determine who we
are and where we belong
say goodbye out your families are you
nervous no I'm terrified
your results were inconclusive
that's impossible is not impossible it's
just extremely rare you're able to
control and conquer your fears they call
it divergent you don't fit into a
category I can't control you
you can't trust anyone you have to hide
inside a faction to survive
welcome to the homeless and this is we
will be watching to see who you really
are you made a mistake choosing
dauntless
they'll find out about you I know what
you are you're afraid of heights
everyone's afraid of something but not
you so it doesn't shut you down and
wakes you up that's what makes you
dangerous
divergents threaten the system it won't
be safe until they're removed she's
gonna kill me
we have to be ready for anything the
world is changing you'll have to decide
who you're loyal to
all of my life I've lived by your rules
not anymore
you